[Musique]
bon notre ca ce soir diane bérard
nicolas duvernois bonsoir alors ottawa
qui annonce la fin de la quarantaine à
l'hôtel pour les canadiens de la cette
idée de sauver de l'argent là qu'on n'a
pas à donner un hôtel lorsqu'on revient
de voyage
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ça on
sent que les choses avancent
peut-être des bourne est ce que ça va
trop vite est-ce que ça va pas trop vite
nicolas
moi j'aimerais pas me retrouver
sincèrement dans la place des leaders
gouvernementaux peu importe le palier
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai une pression
énorme ça fait 18 mois qu'on est cons
finis qu'on a des restrictions toutes
sortes et on a tous en témoin le premier
cependant je crois qu'il faut faire
vraiment attention parce que on a dit à
quel point c'était pénible ces 18
derniers mois là et on voudrait pas
aller trop vite et est sous-estimé le
potentiel danger des variants que on
parle pas trop là on essaye de on essaie
de le mettre en dessous du tapis comme
s'ils n'existaient pas mieux réel danger
donc j'ai vraiment hâte qu'on revienne à
une nouvelle normale mais mais faisons
attention t on n'est pas à deux trois
semaines près de tout gâcher trop rapide
ou trop prudent diane je pense pas qu'on
ait trop prudent je comprends que ça
peut avoir l'air trop lent parce que ça
fait un an et demi puis on a beaucoup de
restrictions mais je pense qu'il faut
pas qu'on perde de vue le méta objectif
le mét objectif c'est l'immunité
communautaire donc c'est le fait
d'arriver à 70% et plus de gens qui ont
eu la deuxième dose
si on regarde ce qui se passe en
grande-bretagne en ce moment les
nouveaux comme la majorité des gens qui
n'ont pas été vaccinés qui n'ont pas eu
leur deuxième dose
donc moi mon inquiétude c'est que à
force d'assouplir rapidement que les
gens en viennent à oublier leur deuxième
dose ou à négliger leur deuxième dose
est là ce n'est pas du tout souhaitable
mais que l'absurde exemple des dodos au
contraire si on dit aux gens
l'accès aux voyages aux déplacements
c'est avec deux doses
est ce que ça vient pas justement
encourager les gens à aller chercher
leur deuxième dose
il faut absolument que l'accès au voyage
soit avec les deux autres que tous
soient liés ou deux doses
c'est ça c'est une sainte essentiel il
faut ok ok aucune pas aucun passe-droit
par rapport à ça parce que si on enlève
les restrictions on va oublier on va
oublier la deuxième dose est donc de
doses nicolas pas d'autres potes
quarantaine à l'hôtel pas de quarantaine
du tout après un test négatif
qu'en pensez vous de ce match
entièrement d'accord parce que ça serait
bizarre qu'on change le discours depuis
depuis la découverte du premier vaccin
on nous hue on nous inonde littéralement
les oreilles avec le fait que le sucre
et de la liberté c'est d'avoir deux
doses donc si on a ces deux aussi
certains vaccins donne une protection de
96% et en plus on rajoute un test
négatif le moment donné nous voulons
tous mes pots segal comment on dit donc
normal en france la réouverture commence
a commencé aujourd'hui et les canadiens
pourront aller en france
les destinations sont classés d'ailleurs
par couleur et chaque couleur à ses
propres restrictions pour les voyageurs
donc pour permettre aux français par
exemple de voyage et nicolas vous pensez
quoi de ce système là est ce qu'on
devrait imiter la france en termes de
sur ces questions de couleur là sur des
destinations
mais pour ceux qui ont vu le film les
douze travaux d'astérix qui se passe en
france
moi qui étais motifs français un mémoire
français mammeri québécoise le port
d'elle que je pourrais venir déjà à
l'avance comment faire les restrictions
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le touristes
qui débarquent vie qui n'est pas de la
bonne couleur andy mais moins d'imprévus
vaccin je crois qu'on se retrouve dans
une situation où il n'y a pas un
scénario jusqu'à preuve du contraire qui
est simple je crois qu'il va avoir
plusieurs mois de casteide de bordels de
pau pour politique avant qu'on revienne
à une logique mais s'avère extrêmement
j'aimerai pas être douaniers dans les
prochains dans les prochains mois il va
voir tout type de cas de défaut sur
question et vaccins qui sortent de nulle
part
régis bien devant ok je vous amène tout
de suite si vous voulez bien dit on va
commencer avec vous sur le dossier de
longue et je veux vous entendre au
dessus gros projet de devimco à
longueuil 1600 unités de logement sur le
terrain le site du terminus est à deux
pas de là il ya un autre groupe qui
s'appelle geste dave qui s'en vient avec
275 appartements des bureaux il ya le
groupe k o de véronique cloutier et
louis morissette entre autres qui
s'installent là la ssq assurance que sa
tour
la mairesse parent a prévu une immense
todd autour de l'université de
sherbrooke avec des commerces salle de
spectacle promenade riveraine
éventuellement le prolongement du métro
éventuellement bon vous en pensez-quoi
diane de tout ça il ya beaucoup de
choses à dire d'abord longueuil
visiblement veut se débarrasser de son
image de ville dortoir avec le règne de
l'auto on ça wright de brooklyn
on sent à travers l'image que longueuil
à cette donnée la ville de l'autre côté
de la métropole avec l'eau avec la
promenade riveraine on se croirait dans
un film de woody allen dans les feuilles
des choses que j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup l'idée de faire une
symbiose entre l'immobilier et le
transport collectif donc de développer
son enseigne aux j'aime beaucoup l'idée
de redéployer des parcs industriels
comme on va faire pour créer une zone
résidentielle
par contre tout tient une chose hein
c'est juste qu'ils allaient qui prend
les décisions
parce que trop cuisiner quand la sauce
d'assos devient fade ou trop piquant
donc est ce que le gouvernement
municipal a vraiment le contrôle de la
situation
est ce qu'il dit en amont ce qu'il
souhaite comme usage de son territoire
est ce qu'ils vont garder le contrôle
est-ce que c'est pas un amalgame de
projets immobiliers qui fait un lieu de
vie un milieu de vie c'est un mélange
complexe de territoire de citoyens des
fraudes structure puisse après impôts de
magic l'a donc la poudre magique c'est
le gouvernement municipal qui est
essentielle à contrôler c'est pour les
promoteurs
nikolov pensez quoi de cette de ce
développement est la vision d'ensemble
aussi du développement urbain qui
s'organise
une ville comme longueuil moi je croyais
que longueuil voulait surtout se
débarrasser de la coupe longueuil mais
bref moi moi moi je vois dans sa une
autre attaque envers montréal montreal
le prochain maire ou la mairesse qui
sera élu va devoir travailler fort dans
les coins comme on pourrait dire pour
pouvoir freiner la désertion
littéralement de montréal parce que
longueuil c'est quoi c'est m vol
d'oiseau on se rappelle que jacques
hôtel on gagne à brossard qui attire
déjà beaucoup ça répond à une demande
la pandémie a complètement changé la
donne de l'attractivité d'une ville
comme montréal et puis c'est pas avec
des pistes cyclables puis des parkings
moins cher qu'on va attirer le monde
massivement pour revenir à montréal
donc je dis les économes et le vélo est
de plus en plus populaires on avait des
statistiques qui hier mon vin de besoin
d'eau et le vélo est très populaire
mais revenons à troguéry connaît mais le
vélo le vélo il va pas traverser le pont
il va rester à longueuil parce que si on
est une personne qui habite en banlieue
et on a un soir ça soit longueuil sur la
rive-sud peu importe presque tous que
montréal offre messin la congestion sent
la chaleur urbaine la telle qu'on la
connaît sans le coût exorbitant des dd
logement à montréal
oui le coût exorbitant des loyers
corporatif souci est donc une entreprise
qui va louer dix ou douze étages dans un
tour mais pourquoi il y aurait il ira
elle irait à montréal étant dangereux
violent non non non en attendant de voir
à quoi ça développement voire de poids
ces développements immobiliers va voir
là il ya déjà deux groupes
donc c'est pas un groupe ces deux
groupes qui on va voir jusqu'à quel
point le comme je dis au gouvernement le
contrôle de la situation s'apaisait du
développement et bonnier savage aussi
c'est pas parce qu'on a tout les besoins
des concepts urbains la mode que ça va
donner un milieu de vie moi je pense que
c'était un peu à la rigueur je pense pas
que non je ne suis pas alarmiste mais
quand le quartier dix30 et néons
gardez ça de avec avec le nez en l'air
las et finalement toutes les tours qui
ont poussé au dix30
elle n'aurait pas pousser en plein
milieu d'un champ des nations je disais
juste qu'on n'a pas déménagé au dix30 ni
toi ni moi qui on est possible de
déménager à longueuil donc à quelque
part il faut voir de quoi ça va avoir la
quelle clientèle est visé excellent oui
bon je pourrais en parler là mais bref
on va on va voir merci beaucoup vous
êtes passionné et passionnant
alors en attendant que ce projet se
réalise on se revoit la semaine
prochaine merci une bonne soirée de
pouvoir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit